die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis herzlich willkommen an
einen schönen guten abend den sport hat
norbert lehmann für sie tollen
showprogramm druck von mir und wir
beginnen die sendung mit der
dienstältesten monarchen der welt
70 jahre königin großbritannien feiert
die 96 jährige elisabeth hunderttausende
sind dabei vier tage lang
im häuserkampf ukrainische soldaten
stemmen sich im donbass gegen die
eroberung strategisch wichtige städte
hohe inflation und auch mehr miete
mieter sorgen sich experten halten
pauschale anpassungen an die inflation
für unzulässig
großbritannien ist im royalen
ausnahmezustand die queen wird gefeiert
mit großem pomp und gloria aus aller
welt gibt es glückwünsche nicht nur zur
nachfeier ihres 96 geburtstages sondern
auch zu ihrem 70 thronjubiläum weltweit
bewundern unzählige menschen sie für
ihren unermüdlichen dienst über eine
außergewöhnlich lange zeitspanne hinweg
so bundespräsident steinmeier mit 25
jahren wurde prinzessin elisabeth über
nacht zur königin als ihr vater könig
georg der sechste 1952 überraschend
verstarb ein jahr später die
krönungszeremonie
inzwischen ist das empire der queen
kleiner geworden krisen und skandale
haben das königshaus erschüttert und die
royals haben an bedeutung verloren trotz
alledem viele menschen in großbritannien
feiern ihre queen ab heute vier tage
lang yasin herrlein
der himmel rot weiß blau die queen auf
dem balkon des buckingham palastes es
war kurz nach 14 uhr deutscher zeit als
der erste höhepunkt dieses thron
jubiläumswochenendes erreicht war
zehntausende hatten sich auf den straßen
und in den parks der londoner innenstadt
eingefunden um sollten die bühnen noch
den am samstag das große konzert
stattfindet und schwenkten fahnen in den
nationalfarben
zuvor shopping.de color die
traditionelle militärparade die stets
anlässlich des geburtstags der königin
abgehalten wird im 70 jahr ihrer
regentschaft wirkte das meer rot weiß
gekleideter soldaten zu fuß und zu
pferde ein stück prächtiger bombastische
nach exit corona und ukraine krieg
nahmen die briten und viele touristen
die einladung zum feiern
mir war klar dass ich heute hier sein
musste denn eine feier wie diese wird es
nicht mehr geben unsere queen ist die
wundervollste aller königin das weiß
jeder
hier wird geschichte geschrieben ich
wollte dass meine kinder dieser
atmosphäre erleben können bis vor kurzem
war der gesundheitszustand der queen so
bedenklich dass nicht klar war an
welchen ereignissen dieses langen
wochenendes der feierlichkeiten sie
überhaupt würde teilnehmen können der
auftritt ihrer majestät auf dem balkon
mit dem rest der königlichen familie
oder daher besonders überschwänglich
bejubelte dazu die große flugschau sogar
mit fliegern der berühmten luftschlacht
um england zweiter weltkrieg shipping
der kaller ein gelungener auftakt der
großen party zum siebzigsten
thronjubiläum königin elizabeth der
zweite
ja wirklich große feiern dabei steckt
das land die an einigen schwierigkeiten
diana zimmermann in london ist das 70
thronjubiläum der queen da so eine art
willkommene ablenkung
die queen hat immer zu einer
willkommenen ablenkung auch weil sie
ebenso sehr viel erstrebenswertes auf
sich vereint sie ist nicht nur
unglaublich beliebte wir heute wieder
bestaunen konnten sowohl bei briten als
auch bei menschen in der ganzen welt sie
ist außerdem sehr wohlhabend und extrem
tugendhaft das komplette
kontrastprogramm also zur realpolitik in
großbritannien momentan der premier
machte schlagzeilen mit skandalen und
ist sogar wegen eines gesetzesbruch es
zu einer strafzahlung verurteilt worden
und die wirtschaft situation im land ist
extrem besorgniserregend das land
steuert auf eine rezession zu es gibt
also nicht viele gründe zu feiern aber
einen anlass und wir uns heute einer der
vielen fröhlichen briten hier nicht ohne
selbstironie sagte feiern sei eben das
was die briten besonders gut können und
das sehen wir auch hinter ihnen
dankeschön diana zimmermann
und vieles über das leben der queen also
fakten und fotos finden sie auch online
bei uns ebenso alles wissenswerte zum
siebzigsten thronjubiläum von elisabeth
der zweiten jederzeit in unserer zdf
heute
blicken wir jetzt in die ukraine dort
dringen die ukrainischen und die
russischen truppen um die kontrolle des
donners also der region donetsk und luca
für die ukraine wird es da militärisch
immer enger im osten würden täglich 100
menschen sterben und 400 bis 500
menschen verletzt so der ukrainische
präsident seelands die über die kämpfe
berichtet anton kuscheligen
russische raketenwerfer feuern auf
ukrainische stellungen diese bilder
sollen zeigen die offensive im osten
geht voran
aus dem don bass werden erneut schwere
gefechte gemeldet häuserkampf in der
industriestadt hier werden jetzt
laut britischen geheimdienst haben die
russen die stadt bereits größtenteils
eingenommen fällt auch ließ sonst hätte
die russische armee die region luhansk
vollständig unter kontrolle und könnte
sich dann auf die angrenzende region
dann jetzt konzentrieren diese straße
führt nach sie werden jetzt sie ist
offenbar noch unter ukrainischer
kontrolle ein kamerateam eines
französischen senders dreht diese bilder
und gerät dann unter beschuss
ein ukrainischer soldat begleitet das
fernsehteam
diese straße ist sehr gefährlich auf der
rechten seite höchstens 5 6 kilometer
entfernt steht russische artillerie sie
bombardieren uns jeden tag
nach ukrainischen angaben versuchen
russische truppen auch von lima und ist
um aus nach kramer tomsk vorzudringen
20 prozent der ukraine seien
mittlerweile von russland besetzt im
osten werde die lage immer schwieriger
so der ukrainische präsident
eine brauchen moderne waffen nur so
können wir dem gegner überlegen sein in
diesem krieg
die reaktion aus moskau kam prompt
sollte die ukraine mit modernen waffen
aus dem westen ziele in russland
angreifen würde das die kriegssituation
signifikant verändern dieses heute aus
dem kreml
jetzt konsequenz aus dem ukraine krieg
soll die bundeswehr jetzt zusätzlich 100
milliarden euro bekommen morgen wird im
bundestag über dieses sondervermögen das
über schulden finanziert wird abgestimmt
die zwei-drittel-mehrheit dafür scheint
sicher nachdem sich der
verteidigungsausschuss darauf geeinigt
hat was genau für das viele geld
beschafft werden soll vor allem die
luftwaffe krieg viele milliarden die
liste hat sich thomas reichert
angeschaut die größte reform für die
bundeswehr seit jahrzehnten nimmt ihre
wichtigste hürde gestern abend fast
grund den markt im
verteidigungsausschuss
union und ampel beschließen das
sondervermögen und was mit den 100
milliarden euro gekauft werden soll für
bekleidung und ausrüstung sind rund zwei
milliarden vorgesehen für die sogenannte
führungsfähigkeit vor allem
verschlüsselte kommunikation 20 7
milliarden für militärische einsätze in
der luft zum beispiel neue flugzeug oder
helikopter
40,8 milliarden für die landstreitkräfte
16,6 milliarden für die seestreitkräfte
19,3 milliarden
diese 100 milliarden in die hand zu
nehmen bedeutet dass wir jetzt intensiv
in die bundeswehr investieren können
überall die fähigkeiten die sie im laufe
der jahrzehnte nach dem hoffnung der
mauer verloren hat sein signal an die
bundeswehr sei ein signal an die
menschen in diesem land dass wir bereits
in einem bundeswehr wieder aufzubauen
die moderne wer fähig ist der größte
batzen geht in die erneuerung von
veralteten fluggerät die tornados seit
40 jahren im dienst sollen abgelöst
werden durch moderne f-35 tarnkappen
bomber auch der ch 53
transporthubschrauber seit 50 jahren im
einsatz wird ersetzt durch ch 47 chinook
es sind ganz viele dinge auf der liste
die die bundeswehr seit jahren vor sich
herschiebt der ersatz der tornados jetzt
mit der f-35 das steht seit jahren an
einen neuen schweren
transporthubschrauber der soll auch
schon seit zwei jahrzehnten beschafft
werden damit nicht nur das geld da ist
sondern am ende auch das gerät mit der
bundestag vor der sommerpause zusätzlich
noch ein gesetz beschließen das die
anschaffung vereinfacht und beschleunigt
früher konnte schon allein das jahre
dauern
um die folgen des russischen angriffs
auf die ukraine ging es auch beim
treffen der spitzen der bundesländer so
forderte nrw-ministerpräsident wüst
abhängigkeiten deutschlands von
autoritären regime künftig umfassend zu
vermeiden die anderen großen themen die
korona pandemie und die hohe inflation
patricia wiedemeier über das treffen in
berlin
endlich mal wieder in präsenz gruppen
bilder wie diese gab es lange nicht mehr
diesmal nicht corona sondern der ukraine
krieg und die folgen im mittelpunkt wie
kann deutschland möglich schnell
unabhängig werden von russischer energie
wie können die bürger weiter entlastet
werden die fragen heute beim vorgespräch
ohne den kanzler es ist ganz klar wir
brauchen auch perspektivisch zielgenaue
unterstützung vor allem für diejenigen
menschen in unserem land die wenig geld
haben
wesentlich länger als geplant dauerte
die erste beratungsrunde der kanzler
musste warten im anschluss dann ein
erster zwischenbericht es ging um
ukraine flüchtlinge weitere
entlastungspaket und um den klimawandel
sind uns einig deutschland muss so
schnell wie möglich unabhängig vom
import russischer energie werden deshalb
wollen wir auch höheres tempo beim
ausbau der erneuerbaren energie sehen
auch dass es vor allem für diejenigen
die geringe einkommen haben und von der
teuerung besonders betroffen sind auch
gerade für die gruppe der rentnerinnen
und rentner aller voraussicht nach die
notwendigkeit geben wird und muss
weitere entlastungsschritte zu ergreifen
seit dem nachmittag sitzen nun
bundesregierung und länder chefs
zusammen im kanzleramt und dort soll es
dann auch um corona gehen die länder
fordern dass der bund sich auf mögliche
neue wellen im herbst vorbereitet große
sorge bei dem thema corona irgendwen wir
sehen der bund hat diese kompetenz
komplett an sich gezogen und er muss
jetzt sagen wir dass er weiter sieht
auch da sind die bundesländer sich einig
der bund müsse dafür sorgen dass es eine
neue rechtsgrundlage und genügend
impfstoff gebe schulschließungen sollen
vermieden werden viel diskussionsstoff
also für das zurzeit noch andauernde
gespräch im kanzleramt
erneut hat sich der ungarische premier
viktor orban quergestellt und
durchgesetzt wegen ihm bleibt der
russisch-orthodoxe patriarch kirill von
strafmaßnahmen der eu verschont dafür
ist das sechste eu sanktionspaket gegen
russland endlich in trockenen tüchern
und tritt morgen in kraft kirill gilt
als vehementer unterstützer von
kremlchef putin
betonte strafen gegen kirchenführer
lehne er aus prinzip ab
polen dagegen zählt zu den eu staaten
die sich am deutlichsten gegen russland
stellen und zuletzt gab es eine
annäherung mit der eu im streit um die
polnische justizreform holen nahm einige
der reformen zurück so dass die
eu-kommission bis der blockierte
milliarden aus dem corona wiederaufbau
fonds an polen freigeben will heute ist
da zur eu kommissionspräsidenten ursula
von der leyen in warschau zu besuch
natalie steger berichtet er ist einer
der richter die suspendiert wurden von
polens disziplinarkammer jetzt darf
pavillons tischen wieder zur arbeit
wurde aber direkt zwangsversetzt von
seinem vorgesetzten
vertrauten des justizministers
für mich ist das eindeutig eine form von
schikanen und repression für die eu
kommissionspräsident in ist es im streit
einer der meilensteine dass polen die
umstrittene disziplinarkammer per gesetz
auflösen will die 35 milliarden corona
aufbau fonds werden freigegeben mit
einem aber eine erste zahlung ist nur
möglich wenn das neue gesetz in kraft
ist wir sind nicht am ende der straße
der rechtsstaatlichkeit in
poland für polen aber scheinen die
differenzen damit vom tisch
wir haben die justizreformen schon vor
jahren angefangen und es kam zu ein paar
meiner meinung nach unnötigen kollision
die disziplinarkammer kommt weg aber
schon hat polens parlament für einen
ersatz bestimmt eine kammer für
sogenannte berufliche verantwortung also
quasi umbenannt das ist keine
verbesserung der justiz situation es ist
ein spiel mit doppeltem boden ein völlig
falsches signal jetzt so viel geld an
polen frei zu geben ohne dass es
mögliche zugeständnisse und
reformversprechen
bei der rechtsstaatlichkeit gibt doch
europa braucht polen als partner gerade
jetzt kein land hat so viele ukrainische
flüchtlinge aufgenommen wie polen
zurück nach deutschland und zu einem
urteil des bundesverfassungsgerichts zu
hartz iv diese staatliche leistung
bekommt auch künftig nur wer über ein
begrenztes vermögen verfügt vorgaben zum
beispiel zur maximalen größe von
wohneigentum sind danach rechtens
geklagt hatte ein ehepaar das allein im
selbst erbauten haus lebt nachdem die
sechs kinder nach und nach ausgezogen
sind ihr antrag auf hartz 4 war
abgelehnt worden
an den geplanten mieterhöhungen des foto
via konzerns hat es jetzt scharfe kritik
von spd generalsekretär kevin kühnert
gegeben dass die rasante
preisentwicklung den immobilienkonzern
zwinge die mieten entsprechend der
inflation zu erhöhen sei zitat grober
unfug so kühn hat steigende mieten sind
vielerorts ein problem wie heiko rams
berichtet athanassios kommt d'antino ist
zufrieden in seiner kleinen
altbauwohnung in neuss bei düsseldorf
doch die steigenden mieten machten dem
rentner sorgen
wird der mitte ist eigen mache es mir
große sorgen können dass nichts mehr
bezahlen dazu steigende energiekosten
und die inflation da sorgt eine aussage
des vorstands von wo novia dem größten
deutschen wohnungsunternehmen
wolfs buch für wirbel er fordert
generell deutliche mieterhöhungen
wenn die inflation dauerhaft bei vier
prozent liegt müssen auch die mieten
künftig jährlich dementsprechend
ansteigen der mieterschutzbund ist
alarmiert und warnt vor dem versuch die
kaltmieten einfach zu erhöhen das sei in
der regel nicht zulässig
ansonsten muss man sich an das
regularium des bürgerlichen gesetzbuches
halten das hat was mit mietspiegel zu
tun mit vergleichsmieten system etc und
da kann man nicht einfach in höhe der
inflationsrate was oben drauf legen
viele mieter müssen einen immer höheren
anteil ihres einkommens für die wohnung
ausgeben eine tendenz die sich
verschärft wir sehen dass die mietpreise
noch die kaufpreise in den großen
metropolen sehr sehr stark gestiegen
sind in den letzten jahren
das wird auch so weiter gehen schlechte
aussichten für mieter wie athanassios
constantino wie lange er sich seine
wohnung leisten kann weiß ja nicht
bei der wahl zum bundespräsidenten hat
der sozialmediziner gerhard trabert
gegen frank walter steinmeier verloren
dafür hat er in ihm aber einen
prominenten unterstützer für sein
anliegen gewonnen gemeinsam wollen sie
auf das thema obdachlosigkeit aufmerksam
machen steinmeier besuchte heute trabert
verein armut und gesundheit in mainz
vielleicht zu beginn besichtigte er das
arztmobil mit dem trabert obdachlose
kostenlos medizinisch versorgt und
steinmeier sprach mit betroffenen
so komme jetzt zum fußball eine arbeit
großer erfolg er für die
nationalmannschaft nationalmannschaft
der ukraine ja ein hochemotionaler 3 zu
1 sieg in glasgow gegen schottland das
team hatte ja angekündigt wir spielen
für unsere landsleute und gegen den
krieg eine ganz besondere motivation am
sonntag geht's gegen aids im playoff
finale um das letzte europäische wm
ticket für katar
das erste pflichtspiel seit kriegsbeginn
kaum vorbereitungen und doch sorgt die
nationalelf der ukraine für einige
stolze momente in ihrer gesunden heimat
trainer alexander petra kopp widmet den
sieg den soldaten und dem personal in
den krankenhäusern
das war nicht mein triumph oder der der
mannschaft wir haben für unser land
gesiegt in der 33 minute bringt andrej
jarmolenko die ukraine in führung kurz
nach der pause erhöhte roman im jahr am
zug auf zwei zu null ein torwart fehler
lässt die schotten in der 80 minute noch
einmal hoffen doch artjom doppik setzt
in der nachspielzeit mit dem 3 1 den
schlusspunkt bei einem sieg in cardiff
würde die ukraine zum zweiten mal nach
2006 an einer wm teilnehmen
fußball-bundesligist hertha bsc hat
einen neuen trainer gefunden
die berliner verpflichten den mainzer
ex-coach sandro schwarz der von dynamo
moskau an die spree wechselt und von der
themse zu real madrid wechselt sie
verteidiger antonio rüdiger der deutsche
nationalspieler trainiert ja zurzeit mit
dem dfb-team in herzogenaurach das sich
dort auf die 4 nations league spiele
vorbereitet
antonio rüdiger hatte gut lachen ob
seines neuen vertrages seien jetzt
ehemalige chelsea kollege timo werner
sorgte seinerseits mit einer
slapstick-einlage für große heiterkeit
bei sühne und gabri bei bester laune hat
bundestrainer flick heute vor allem
standards auf das trainingsprogramm
gesetzt zwei tage vor dem duell mit dem
europameister ohne wm-ticket denke wir
unterschätzen den amtierenden
europameister trotzdem nicht wissen um
ihre qualität und deswegen ja freuen wir
uns auch auf so ein großes spiel was wir
jetzt am wochenende in italien haben
werden und die freude im team ist
tatsächlich nicht zu übersehen
das was im sport
was das wetter angeht beginnt der tag
morgen noch sehr freundlich später aber
drohen von südwesten gewitter männer
zugleich von katja hornuf und bereits um
21 40 gibt es das heute journal mit
marietta slomka machen sie es gut
[Musik]
guten abend für viele von ihnen war das
heute sicherlich ein sehr angenehmer
junitag es gab nur wenige dichte wolken
in norddeutschland und einige
regenschauer im süden jetzt in der nacht
kann es im südwesten auch mal für ein
kurzes gewitter reichen häufig ist es
aber auch klar und da wird es wieder
kalt dann sinken die temperaturen hier
in magdeburg in hamburg oder der
lüneburger heide bis 3 grad das heißt
dort kann es auch nochmal für bodenfrost
reichen milder bleibt die nacht an der
nordseeküste und auch im süden und
südwesten bei 14 bis 10 grad und morgen
sind die temperaturen recht
unterschiedlich an der nordsee bleibt es
kühl mit 17 grad aber im
rhein-main-gebiet klettern die werte auf
29 grad und der tag geht erst mal mit
sehr viel sonnenschein draußen
süddeutschland sind die wolken etwas
dichter da kann es aus der nacht heraus
hier und da auch noch mal ein bisschen
regnen und dann beginnt es zu quellen es
gibt kräftige gewitter die zielrichtung
saga und rheinland pfalz aber auch nach
baden württemberg und bayern das können
zum teil lokale unwetter seien gewitter
die mit hagel platzregen und sturmböen
verbunden sind in der nacht zu samstag
ziehen sie weiter nach osten die
nächsten unwetter drohen dann am
pfingstsonntag und die erreichen dann am
pfingstmontag den osten in
abgeschwächter form guten abend